i'm gonna i want to pull up this tweet
from matt walsh
matt walsh says absolutely damning there
is no defending this 19 officers waited
outside and listened to children get
slaughtered i hope all of these cowards
are sued into bankruptcy they deserve
prison too but i doubt that's going to
happen
let me read for you this excerpt that
matt posted
the authorities now say that local
officers first entered the school at 11
35
two minutes after the gunman
and that there were 19 officers in the
hallway by 1203 pm but that they did not
breach the door and killed the gunman
until 12 50 even as they continued to
hear him firing i just want to just want
to pause
and perhaps tug at your heartstrings
maybe a little bit i want you to imagine
being in the hallway hearing 10 year old
children being shot
from a high-powered rifle
and and with 19 people around you armed
and i want you to imagine what must
possibly be going through your head to
think i'm not gonna do anything
i can't fathom that i oh i'm this
wrecked me when i read this tweet
it's wrecking me now i'm wondering what
they knew the cops did they think there
were multiple shooters was it possible
there were multiple shooters that it was
they were firing on purpose in there to
draw them in to kill the cops like what
did they know i think they were gonna
i think what was the first thing they
said but they could have got shot is
that what it was look i'll tell you from
from my view having worked with law
enforcement in the intelligence
community uh when you're going
face-to-face with uh really awful evil
people
um
you just go
and you you get into this line of work
because you know that you're there
because other people can't be or won't
be and so you take that man along you
know that you're gonna throw yourself
into harm's way and uh the people who
love you your spouses your kids they
know that that's the agreement that you
have it's just in your heart and so
you know the extent to which this did or
didn't happen i don't know but if i i'll
tell you if you had a bunch of guys in a
hallway who knew that this slaughter was
happening
and they put aside their oath and their
commitment to those kids their community
because they were afraid for their own
lives while at some level i think most
of it can can understand like hey we
want to preserve ourselves
when you sign up to be a law enforcement
official or an intelligence officer you
understand that your body at some level
belongs to the mission and you go you go
in and you know that you will sacrifice
yourself that's just what you sign up
for i don't i don't you know that it
sounds very logical
i don't know that i would be affected in
that way i think the moment i heard
screaming and the guns i'd just be
kicking the door in yeah i can't i can't
i don't think i'd be able to think
straight but that's the point most
people that i've ever worked with in law
enforcement they come to the table with
that orientation in their heart that's
just what they do because they know that
they're going to be called on to do that
it doesn't matter who your kids are or
your spouses or whatever when you hear
that moment when you see that that
person needs to be taken down you go and
you know that you can put yourself in
our way
real quick sorry man i just have you
ever watched a movie where there's like
medieval warfare or ancient warfare or
even colonial aero warfare and i always
thought every mil gibson movie ever made
female games all of them the patriot is
one of my favorite movies of all time
and i when i watch these movies
i always see those guys on the front
line with the spears or whatever and i'm
like they know they're going to die
and they've they stand there knowing
they are going to die
and it's remarkable because that's
something you choose to walk up to stand
there and say this is it yeah when when
in this circumstance i'm just like this
is the exact opposite of that yeah these
are the people who are like i'm not
going in front and they they can hear
children being shot i can't i can't
understand i have run into danger for
stupider reasons than that when i worked
for these these media companies and the
we hear the gunshots and we hear the the
flashbangs go off and we take cover and
we slowly try going towards it just to
film it just just to film because we
want to show people what's happening let
alone trying to save the life of a child
i i my brain doesn't understand this i
just don't get it i just can't it
doesn't the brain doesn't process it
because even if it weren't the gunshots
if they just said on the other side of
this door or some children who were shot
you can't fathom standing there for 30
minutes and saying oh yeah there were
kids shot on the other side of the store
like they knew there were people who had
been shot you you are looking for triage
you're looking to
so it just it just it doesn't make sense
and i'm not saying it didn't happen i i
it just it it defies logic it defies
emotion it defies human nature it defies
the nature of of law enforcement which
does have that race in and save the day
it just it's it's it doesn't i mean
look you've got you left and right
publications are are
essentially unified on the cnn's
reporting they waited in the hallway 19
people
that's just i don't know it doesn't make
any sense i'll tell you working with a
lot of guys in the military uh they will
they have told me stories no doubt
people who are listening to watching
right now probably know what i'm about
to say in terms of when you've got your
brothers next to you
and if there's somebody coming at you
you get up and you fire you take care of
the threat you do it for yourself you do
for the people who are around you
there's a brotherhood and a sisterhood
that you're in this for the mission but
it's also because you're doing this for
your country you know in this way you
know you're doing it for your community
you're doing it for those kids and those
families but you're doing it for your
community because you love your
community you want to defend it from any
threat
foreign exactly the exact same thing in
the military you know those guys do it
for their country because they love
their country so i don't know what the
heck has gone on here but but something
is very very wrong i got ratio today on
twitter because i said this is what this
is what happens when you defund the
police you get incompetent officers
and the response from the right was
these were fully funded officers and
they have no obligation to defend
anybody and the left said the same thing
these are this department was never
defunded and so i'm gonna eat that one
and i'm gonna own up to the to the poor
wording of the idea
what i was thinking of when i was
tweeting that was
this is what happens after quote-unquote
defund the police yeah not i i didn't
mean to say that this department was
specifically defunded i said when you
demonize police
when you memorialize criminals
this is what you'll get
why would an officer
they're thinking themselves if i go in
there they're going to blame me they're
going to you know they're going to say
oh he started shooting because you did
it they will throw so no one is willing
to take the actions anymore yeah i was
imagining that from their perspective
maybe in like fog of war they didn't
know what was going on if there were
multiple shooters if it was a hostage
situation if however there are three
guys in there with ar-15s trained on the
door ready for cops just to walk through
one by one and take them down one by one
and they're like we're not going to add
to the bloodshed that's what i'm trying
to figure someone had mentioned that
cops do not rush towards an armed man
that they can't see because they will
get shot
what are we going to say brian this idea
though uh building on what you both have
just said this idea of risk aversion
right so if you right now or in a law
enforcement capacity in this country
you know that if you step incorrectly
you are going to be under a massive
microscope irrespective of your intent
so could there have been an issue here
where some of those people particularly
collectively or like oh god if we do the
wrong thing here or the cameras are
going to be outside and we're all going
to get nailed for this to what extent is
there a risk aversion sort of culture
developing within law enforcement
because of this sort of the the woke
stuff or even some degree of actually
you know good scrutiny over what people
in law enforcement you know have done
historically but has it gone too far has
a pendulum swung too far
i think that that could also potentially
be something that we're looking at here
well the last two democrat presidents
one being the current and the one
before trump you know the day this
happened or two days ago they were
talking about george floyd and talking
about the need for police accountability
so
when you say have we taken it too far
yeah who who wants to be a cop right now
you know and this just makes it worse
right now everyone's you're going to be
a cop did you know 19 of them stood in
the hallway and and now you have to be
collectively joined to that you're all
cops it's like i i i don't want to be
part of that type of cop but i want to
be a cop but not anymore i don't if this
is what it means if every time i do
something you're going to subpoena my
body cam footage to have nbc edit it in
a way that makes me look like the
screw you i don't know we use this for
38 grand a year and we desperately need
heroes right yeah we do yeah if they if
in the military if those soldiers didn't
have the authority to mow down civilians
at will in the heat of the moment that
we would lose every war yeah you need
that vicious
onslaught you need it or you cannot win
a war that's war but these people it
basically was as similar as like a war
moment of war in the classroom but i
think this is different but i see what
you're saying you you know you need a
certain level of vigor and and you know
when it comes to outright war
but when you're in war it's different
from when you're hearing children dying
right next to you i
i i i have no words to explain like the
correlation is that their their
authority to be brutal has been stripped
away from them i'm not saying that it's
good for cops to be brutal but i think
that in some cases they need to feel
like they can be in order to survive
i would only offer brother that i think
that
there is a good thing that we teach both
in law enforcement the intel community
and military and that is target
discernment so understanding who's in
front of you and whether or not to pull
the trigger and i think that a certain
bridling of that raw human nature that
just wants to throttle and kill it's not
such a bad thing actually it's quite
good so some discernment around target
selection is is brilliant but your point
and this is really important in in that
fog of war and that intensity when your
adrenaline is pumping
are you going to make that perfect
decision 100 times out of 100 times
right
no and we know that whether it be in
intel law enforcement or military you're
going to make mistakes and mistakes are
going to happen and so that's when i
think as a as a country we need to be
able to have that moment of reflection
to say
someone made a mistake it doesn't mean
all law enforcement or good or bad or
let's be careful with our our statements
not to make sweeping swooping
generalizations but maybe a bit more
nuanced but the bottom line i think that
a little bit of target discernment is
really important it's really good but i
think in this case something just didn't
go well didn't go
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there